to its two parts. You've got cryptos and graphy, and both of those have Greek roots. In fact,
if you look at the word.
We are now going to focus on the importance that cryptography provides in helping achieve.
We are now going to focus on the importance that cryptography provides in helping achieve security
services, and you're going to see that cryptography today is fundamental. In achieving not just one,
but five really important security services that have become really important in the security
industry. But before we get into that, if you look at the word cryptography itself and you break it
up into its two parts, you've got cryptos and graphy, and both of those have Greek roots. In fact,
if you look at the word cryptos, it translates into the word secret and graphy translates into the
word writing. So cryptography is all about writing secrets, and the obvious reason why we want to
turn something into a secret is to keep it confidential. So confidentiality is the main goal of
cryptography, but as you will see, there are some other ones that have become really important
that cryptography can help us achieve in today's environments. In fact, these are the five services
that cryptography can achieve, and very effectively. The first, of course, is confidentiality. There's
nothing better than cryptography to achieve confidentiality services. In fact, we've known that for
thousands of years, and that's why cryptography has been used throughout history, mostly to achieve
confidentiality, but in today's environments, there's nothing better than confidentiality to really
achieve that goal in a really large way. Now, cryptography can also help us with integrity,
and what we mean by integrity typically is this. If I send you a message, when you receive that message,
you want to know that nothing happened along the way, because things could happen along the way.
For example, someone can change it purposely, or errors can happen in transmission, but regardless
of what caused the change, we want to be able to identify that that information has changed
along the way. So that's what integrity really means from a cryptography perspective, and to make
this really easy for us, and for you, from an exam perspective. What you want to do is you want to
equate integrity to hashing. That's how we achieve integrity or message integrity controls in
cryptography through hashing. So hashing equals integrity. Integrity equals hashing. If you connect those
two, it's going to be really useful to you. Now, we have to understand what hashing is. Hashing by
definition is what we call one-way encryption. As opposed to two-way encryption. Two-way encryption
means we can take something and turn it into a secret, but then we can take that secret, which is
usually referred to as ciphertext, and turn it back into the original plaintext. That's two-way
encryption. We can encrypt and decrypt. Two-way encryption requires keys, because keys is what makes
it easy to encrypt, but also what makes it easy to decrypt at the other end. That's what we call two-way
encryption. Hashing, which addresses integrity, by definition is only one-way. We take our data that
we're going to send, for example, and then we one-way encrypt it, and it produces something
typically called a digest that can be useful in addressing whether something happens along the
way. And of course, we're going to look at these methods as we go through this presentation and show
you exactly how each of these are achieved by using cryptography services. But for now, just
equate integrity to hashing. Hashing means we go one-way does not require keys. Now, the third
service that cryptography can provide for us is what we call authenticity. And some people
refer to this as proof of origin. So don't confuse it with authentication of people. That's not what
this service is in regards to authenticity or proof of origin. Means that we can authenticate and
know where something came from. So if I send you a message, you'll be able to prove that it actually
came from me by using cryptography services. And that in today's environments may be very important.
And here's a perfect example. If we want to patch our Microsoft operating systems,
we want that patch to actually come from Microsoft. So we may ask Microsoft to do something related
to cryptography so that when that patch comes to us, we can do something related to cryptography
that it proves to us that that patch actually came from Microsoft and not some other organization
pretending to be Microsoft. That's what we refer to as authenticity or proof of origin.
The next service that cryptography can provide for us is non-repudiation. The key word here is the
word repudiation. If you look that up in a dictionary, it means to be able to deny. So non-repudiation
means the inability to deny. You cannot deny having done something. So if I send you a message,
I cannot say later that it wasn't me that sent that particular message. That's what we call
non-repudiation. And very effectively, we can achieve this in cryptography. And what you want to
do here, just like we equated integrity to hashing. Hashing equals integrity, integrity equals
hashing. We can do the same thing here to make it easy for you. We can equate non-repudiation
to digital signatures. So non-repudiation equals digital signatures, digital signatures equals
non-repudiation because that's how we achieve this service called non-repudiation. Now what you
also need to remember here is that there are two flavors of non-repudiation. And these are the
correct terms that we need to use because they are the correct terminology used in the industry.
There is non-repudiation of origin, origin, which means the sender, me as the sender, cannot say that
it wasn't me that sent a particular message. You'll be able to prove it. That's non-repudiation
of origin. The sender cannot deny having sent or done something. There's also non-repudiation of
delivery. Delivery means you as the receiver of a message cannot say that you've received a
different message than the one that you actually did receive. So that's non-repudiation of delivery
and both as you'll see later are achieved through digital signatures because that's how we
achieve non-repudiation. And the last service that cryptography can provide for us is a form of
access control. Now you know what access control means means allowing people to access certain
resources. You're authorizing people to be able to access certain resources. And here's how cryptography
can achieve that. I can encrypt a file or some asset and then give you the key or some people the
key to be able to decrypt it, which means I'm authorizing those individuals to be able to access
that file or that resource. So that's a form of access control. And of course you need to remember
these five services or memorize them because they are the five services that can be achieved
through cryptography and very important in today's environments to achieve all of these or some
level of each of these and cryptography can do a really good job in each one as you'll see as we
go through this presentation. Now there's two ways that people refer to for example data and how
it needs to be protected. Now some people would actually argue that there's a third state that data
can be in. But you've heard of these data at rest means that we are storing something onto some
sort of device or technology. And data in transit also referred to as data in motion means that
data is moving usually across networks. Bottom line is cryptography in how it achieves those five
services can be used to protect both data at rest and data in transit. The third state that some
people argue also exist is data in use but that's particularly challenging to protect and cryptography
really can't help us with that. So we're going to talk about that later on. But for now just remember
that cryptography can protect data at rest and data in transit or in motion as it's moving across
networks. Now where is cryptography used today? And these are just a sampling of some of the examples
and architectures and technologies where it's obviously useful to use cryptography. Today cryptography
is everywhere and you know cryptography has been around for thousands of years but it's over the
last number of decades that we've really realized that cryptography can be useful in achieving those
five services in all kinds of applications and environments some of which you see here on this
screen plus a whole bunch more.